ragazzi prima di cominciare a rifarvi
soltanto notare una cosa che non lo
capisce io ho aperto il gioco perché
volevo giocarlo ovviamente mi sapete una
schermata con su scritto ok
e se io dico questo unico tasto che c'è
perché ci sono questo vedete mi porta al
gioco c'è poi adesso mi stile jackie e
cazzo serve con la schermata inutile ho
sprecato 10 secondi nella mia vita è
bella a tutti ragazzi è pervenuti a
questo video sono fa dj oggi siamo su
overcast video che vi invio roll che mia
mi ha incuriosito soprattutto perché
parte con la scritta game ci siamo
ragazzi per me bello ciancio un braccio
fantastico capellini il cognome già mi
fa paura ragazze comunque che c'è un
braccio o troppo figo quindi c'è una
lanterna il sir amnesia praticamente
però non ho capito dove c'è una freccia
io vado di più a posto grazie non
dovrebbe essere di cosenza la mia arma
carica lo trovo questa conquista una
carica di cui parli amico mi fossi 50
casi riscontrati ma se porte sono
possedute ho sollevato una serie si
possono sollevare le sedie già mio gioco
preferito questo cos'è sta roba posso
portare gioca alla sedia perfetta è
andata a controllare è una gran passo
cazzo sì ma quasi sprofondano i gradini
non è che ok il caso lo stop dio cioè
ragazzi cè un [ __ ]
mi è crollato il soffitto bello grazie
molto gentile possa prenderlo e adesso
si fanno i culi da sé la madonna i colpi
di sopra fantasma che c'è un proiettile
che fluttua fantastico
avete sentito anche voi la corda ragazzi
ci siamo che che dei posti poi mamma mio
dio
il fuoco più reale che abbia mai visto
ragazzi giuro e belli ma dai mi sono già
in cassa questo nomi che un sacco mi
sembra una persona domanda vado vado
dove c'è il puntino luminoso modo di qua
nella chi è questa e la chiesa
fantastico la chiesa in sei posti non è
mai il massimo per almeno il fuoco è
bellissimo qualcuno mi spiega cosa devo
fare il suo gioco che ancora non ho
capito rega cos'è la chiave
ho trovato una chiappello mi piace molto
interessante che cosa dovrei farmene gli
starò ad andare laggiù perfetto
all'arredo se vi è soli punti fa bella
sta seria io non so vado avanti ma chi è
quel monache sbatte le porte così anche
i pasti stronzi c'è un ospitalità che
casa store a batterlo ragazzi e questo
sexy sta cosa possa portarmi saga lo que
yo ragazzi o una gamba e non ho paura di
usarsi aperta e allora siete stronzi e
cioè non potete sbattermi le porte così
perché adesso una ghianda ve la faccio
pagare il primo che mi si presenta
davanti a una pedata in faccia e non con
la mia gamba riuscì a capire dove devo
andare a di qua perfetto vandalico ha
permesso io ho una gamba da restituire
sé perché se qualcuno
ragazzi stato tu vedi che vedi che
finisci male la mia gamba la mia gamba è
letale
non ho capito chi è che che è stato a
far estroverso ma non importa io la mia
gamba proseguiamo porta sbloccata
ragazzi ragazzi così caschi
porca [ __ ] che ginocchiata ho dato
mi chiave volato al mouse arc ha
chiamato il dottore per l'amor di dio
che cosa cazzo e successi cos'è questo
di sicuro non ho sentito più male di
quanto non abbia sentito sto cavallo
però tira una botta un po più forte
finivo anch'io così ho mollato un attimo
la mia gamba scelta sbagliatissima
perché ho rischiato di morire allora una
sega devo andare semplicemente di qua
sto sia per un cancello a un cancello
perfetto regalo ok c'è gente altra gambe
al traggano ma la mia più bella la mia
più bella
cavazza quanto sei figo
mi portò la gamma io non ho capito che è
un altro sì ma che cos'è il ragazzino
nazista andiamo avanti lo stesso c'è un
letto mi fa piacere che la gente qui si
diverta a modo suo
non ho capito che sto scusami scusa non
volevo disturbare di tipo no cazzo ma mi
guarda mi hanno preso a calci tranquilli
è tutto a posto si può fare che adottava
i gamba pensaci tu mai mettersi contro
stack a mio zio che potenza ragazzi ho
trovato mia moglie e la mia donna questa
alve senta io ho trovato questa gamma e
mihaela poi l'appoggio un attimo si può
così con una chiave sentimi sarebbe la
chiave i tuoi adesso ti alzi dove la mia
gamba ragazzi no no non me li dai subito
sei uno stronzo di merda che cazzo è
successo ogni volta che mi innamoro di
qualcuno quel qualcuno sarà dalle gambe
da gamba c'è la finestra che più grossa
di me però dovendo entrare con la chiave
è giusto che poteva aiutarmi sto casino
della madonna e poteva ancora avere la
mia gamba se sono stati fosse entrato
dalla finestra
buongiorno che cazzo era qualcosa
brutta in sip ostico trovato una
bottiglia dai sarai un ottimo sostituto
che continua a trovare chiavi ma chi
sarà facile che il cuscino bastare
allora noi o io o la moglie ancora più
bella adesso ciò il cuscino che è molto
più figo bambini e dalla città perfetto
dove si va comunque ho perso la mia
gamba e non mi ha dato a giusta cosa
ragazzi mi dispiace [ __ ] tutto non
mi piace cucinare voleva la mia gamba
maledizione io vorrei farvi vedere il
pozzo che mi è uscito sul ginocchio
perché ho dato una botta che dio mio
santomanco la seconda guerra mondiale i
bombardamenti make up on fire evo devo
fare un fuoco fantastico caso lo faccio
a fare che c'è già a terra posso
prendere sto cose non ci posso creare a
passo d'uomo mentre tutti sti cosi ma
che cazzo serve che il fuoco è sempre
uguale se io avessi la mia gamba questo
avrei già provati tutti invece no
dove cazzo è l'ultimo adesso c'era un
cosa con due miliardi di tronchi
potevate dirlo prima e non importa
niente
ma basta che ritrova la mia gamba e son
contento di 20 ragazzi lo scopo lista
ciò che è stato di ritrovare la gamba
che cazzo succede
sono andato sotto effetto di droghe cosa
è successo ti sei fumato cosa cazzo il
fatto ma non sono io non sono finiti
ragazzi e ragazze ma tu sei figo
prestabilito petri ma no non ho il cazzo
cos'è questa merda
ok sukalo preso ma lo sta prendendo mi
spiegate se lo sto prendendo che non ho
ancora capito
sì ma c'è una mira di merda veloce
nicchia guarda che non ho scalato sei
morto luca è morto questo spararne un
altro con sicurezza
ragazzi io io vi giuro che se mi salta
addosso
vi giuro lo spengo ok che è successo è
stato avvelenato che mi sono avvicinata
sono un deficiente mi sono avvicinato io
c'è ma si può esservi deficienti c mi
sono avvicinato che era morto e mi ha
avvelenato da morto
che tristezza
[Musica]
sebbene mi ha quasi ammazzato e invece
io nel culo gliel'ho via zara queste
sono le canzoni che fanno un casino tra
un po vendo il cd probabilmente un
essere umano sarebbe già morto
avvelenato proprio io sono un capo e con
due maroni così ma senti indovinati ma
cioè ecco per siamo arrivati si può
andare dove vogliono andare adesso che i
ragazzi york e poi dalla fonte appena
sbarcata in città e ha fame di gambe la
mia gamba di nuovo che l'ho persa sì sì
sì
[Musica]
non me ne frega 16 ragazzo ritrovato la
mia gamba sono contentissimo e ai
proiettili soltanto tu no scusami
scusami gamba non volevo giuro
[Musica]
aveva affanculo n'è un altro perfetto
ragazzi ora che siamo tipo protetti
perché ho la mia gamba dove qualcuno va
avanti come cazzo succede
cos'è cos'è cosa brutta [ __ ] e stata
la gamba che si è vendicato perché tipo
prima gli ho sparato in faccia credo si
propone di andarci anche più un piano e
tesoro non è che avevi bisogno di fare
sul caso in programma e non lo sono
meritato va bene questo glielo devo dire
perché non è possibile
princi del cazzo è successo ma si
passare un secondo tranquilli la
raggiunge la cima della montagna si
prosegua cosa si sta muovendo cazzo
regala e dietro il no no no
non scherzate no no no oggi aggirati
gira no grazie a un altro basilisco no è
un altro serpente no un altro serpente
nomi girone palle ragazzi ragazzi che
cazzo non puoi uccidere questa creatura
ma poi rallentarla sì ma che creatura è
ragazzi ragazzi non ho capito che merda
merda è un lupo bruttissimo però devo
muovere il culo perché sennò tipo mi
ammazzo nella madonna che è figlio che
sei sentito non sbaglia lo sbarazzo sì
ma non spara una serie action pardòn
care del cazzo ragazzi sì ho trovato il
pop madonna che bel ponte rassicurante
ragazzi meno non è sorretto da una sega
sto coso va bene c'è ancora no è
perfetto meno male che spari tu non puoi
passare su cado caricare però infatti
avanti si ok ragazzi non mi ha ucciso
[Musica]
ok ok ho vinto che è stata la mia gamba
che lo montano mi ha pensato e sono mi
sono protetto ci siamo gli unici sarkozy
è un po di buttarmi mi butto mi butto
sono sono molto credo credo è non lo so
però potrebbe essere ok
grazie a dio da chiaro ragazzini possono
chiudere qui come primo episodio perché
è stato traumatico a dir poco non sto
scherzando e mio ginocchio chiede pietà
con che ragazzi se però non mi piace che
mettete il mio ginocchio riceverà una
pacca sulla spalla anche se un ginocchio
non ha le spalle leader che ha servito è
piaciuto ma solito lascia un commento mi
piace anche a facili facebook e co meno
di villa platea descrizione se avresti
scritto lì ci vediamo al prossimo video
dei ragazzi